one of her company will turn against her
we don't get a Cassandra how could you
betray Rapunzel like that she's stuck by
your side no matter what and trusted you
as though you were her very own sister
what's most compelling though is that
you've risked your life to save
Rapunzel's I guess she really doesn't
have you bang only to turn around to
betray her out of the blue we seriously
hope you have a valid explanation
Cassandra will give you the benefit of
the doubt for now but honestly the only
way we'll forgive you is if you were
cloned or brainwashed he tried to warn
you Rapunzel
we had to pick our jaws up off the floor
after watching the season 2 finale of
Rapunzel's tangled adventure
Rapunzel isn't going to take this
betrayal lightly so we expect to see the
Disney princess go through some changes
watch until the end to find out Hakkasan
just betrayal will affect Rapunzel on
April 14th
fans of Rapunzel's tangled adventure
found out the truth about Rapunzel's
lady-in-waiting
Cassandra no one expected Cassandra to
go behind Rapunzel's back and take the
moonstone for herself but that's exactly
what happened in the episode titled
destinies collide after reaching the
outskirts of the Dark Kingdom Eugene
came face to face with his long-lost
father King Edmund who explained his
family's reputation of guarding the opal
utterly confused by lords a mantis his
prophecy Eugene forbade Rapunzel's
passage into the castle I'm sorry but
changed his mind when he realized that
his decision mirror to the prophesized
betrayal against his better judgment
King editon granted passage to Eugene
Cassandra and Rapunzel and that's when
everything went awry Cassandra snatched
the moonstone before Puzzle could get
her hands on it and transformed into a
blue haired villain Cassandra reminded
Rapunzel you have to be careful
giving the princess a brand-new dose of
trust issues as it turns out lord amanda
says prophecy came true and now the
kingdom of Corona and all who reside are
in dire jeopardy
but how will Cassandra's actions affect
Rapunzel in season three let's jump
right in and find out season three of
Rapunzel's tangle of interest set to air
on October 7th 2019 but this time the
season will premiere with a special
one-hour long episode the season will
take off for season two left off in the
wake of Cassandra's unsightly betrayal
unable to process Cassandra's actions
Rapunzel and Regina will return to
Corona in a state of total shock only to
find out that their fight is far from
over as it turns out the kingdom of
Corona will have been taken over by an
old enemy and some fans are certain that
this enemy is the one and only Jean
theory but that remains to be seen
to save her people Rapunzel will have to
look within herself and find the
strength she didn't know was there I
can't believe it everyone is depending
on the princess of Corona and her
friends to save the day but with their
morale is at an all-time low
Rapunzel Eugene and the few friends who
remain will have to fight harder than
ever before but the question is does
Rapunzel have any fight left in her
after all she's been betrayed one too
many times to say that Rapunzel already
had trust issues would be an
understatement after all she was raised
by her kidnapper and maid to hide out in
a tower for the first 18 years of her
life
let's get back to your Tower Rapunzel
has been lied to imprisoned and used by
the people she loved the most
her fake mother Gothel was the first to
strike followed by Rapunzel's very own
father King Frederick who also imposed
on her freedom and now Rapunzel's been
betrayed by her lady-in-waiting turned
best friend Cassandra if vanellope von
schweetz thought Rapunzel was paranoid
before wait until the princesses meet
for a second time
the King Frederick and mother Gotham's
betrayal are nothing compared to
Cassandra's after all it was Rapunzel's
choice to let Cassandra into her life
gain Rapunzel's trust isn't an easy
thing to do we mean the girl doubts
everything that moves for crying out
loud
since when did you stop trusting my
judgment by Cassandra risked her life
for Rapunzel's many times over and
showed Rapunzel that she was there for
her both emotionally and physically
Rapunzel and Cassandra had a very
special bond
but Rapunzel's unwillingness to trust
anybody could have pushed Cassandra to
reconsider their friendship
despite being friendly thoughtful and
loyal the puzzle had some faults of her
own of course I trust you we and now it
looks like her trust issues are going to
take a turn for the worst so how will
Cassandra's betrayal affect Rapunzel's
judgment in season three well in a
negative way of course but only at first
Rapunzel is going to need all the help
she can get to defeat whoever took over
Corona in her absence
but overpowering this huge evil isn't
something someone can do alone
especially without the moonstone so
Rapunzel is going to need to learn to
trust people again sooner than later
everyone's had my back this far
Rapunzel may appear more reserved
pensive and reckless in the brand-new
season and she might start to doubt
everyone closest to her be at Eugene his
best friend Lance and whatever allies
come her way but you can't save a
kingdom on your own so Rapunzel will
have to change up her game plan
eventually the Saunders betrayal came as
a major shock but Rapunzel is strong
enough to learn from her mistakes and
move on in the ends for puns expected
everyone to trust her without offering
to trust them in return time to hit the
road which is a surefire ways to create
dishonest relationships
Rapunzel might be shell-shocked at first
but Cassandra's actions will make her
stronger than ever before especially
once she defeats Cassandra and reek
Korona well you guys surprised when
Cassandra took the moonstone for herself
or did you see her betrayal coming from
a mile away
sound off in the comments and that's a
wrap subscribe to our channel and give
this video a big thumbs up thanks for
watching the things we'll see you next
time
[Music]